all right
amber welcome back again
so what's the latest okay um you've had
a rough
couple of months right yes exactly okay
so
the first latest is that i
tested positive for covet and i was sick
and i found out while i was sick that
there's not many resources were homeless
people
so i was stuck but the best part is
today i'm going to rehab you decide to
go to rehab
i have to go to rehab my life have
become
completely unmanageable
i i give up i tap out
that's probably a great thing right yes
your life would seem to be spiraling
downward ever since our first i'm burped
out as the phrase would go you know i'm
burnt out
if you look at that before almost as bad
as some of the other people
i know um through here yeah i'm burnt
out i can't do it anymore
okay i get between my life and the life
that i was
the street life in my life
i'm destroyed i destruct it
so when you're leaving today today yes
like 90 days 90 days yeah have you done
rehab before
this will be my fourth rehab try since
2015.
so thank you saying just keep coming
back and i keep going back
this has got to be different this time
though i mean is the core of the problem
with addiction is
is it really the drug or is it the the
trauma you go through as a kid and all
the shame from
all the bad decisions it's it's the
trauma
i mean your kids cause a lot of shame
and pain for you i'm sure and that's
hard to
deal with so the drugs numb that and
then you
yeah it's like a downward spiral yeah
the trauma childhood trauma then adult
trauma then having children
and afraid to traumatize them yes
for me my problem is my life
or my issues in my life the drugs are
just what
i use to get through hit or cope
i guess i don't know but i gotta go back
i have to i want my life back some part
of it
yeah that would be nice to see you
do some of the things you talked about
in that first interview right
so at least one thing you know something
i feel like a
failure but i'm gonna be okay i'll be
okay
i just basically came down your mark
today because i want
to thank you the most because you've
been really there for me
here for me and i don't think i would
have gotten this far without you
so i really want to tell you thank you
and also i want you to see if what
before i went because when i come back
i'm going to be defense happiness
so that's what my that's in my mind yeah
well i mean you've
you've been through a lot this year
and i would love to see your intelligent
beautiful woman i would love to see you
kind of get your
your life together it'd be so great to
see that but
there's only so much i can do i can i
can put you in a hotel room for a week
and i can
help you with this that and the other
but but that's not really going to fix
anything
right now it's my turn to do my part
because
you and other people have stepped in for
me
so now it's time for me to put my words
its actions
yeah i think courage is what is is the
piece of the puzzle that a lot of people
just don't have
can't come up with love and courage
forgiveness there's a lot of things but
uh
just want to make a change
see what happens yeah i think um
i was coming to that final thoughts
fix it or die i'm not ready to diet
yeah because you'll end up dead living
that life right yeah
living the life in the lifestyle and
just all the drama
of people that are living that that
lifestyle
working figaro or similar
tracks around the city or around the
country how many how many of them you
think are addicted to drugs
i don't know i mean well yeah high
versus dominant 40
i'm not really sure in my area
it's a high high say 75 percent
in my area but i'm sure there's other
tracks where there's like
girls out there getting their money
they're not worried about even smoking a
cigarette
you know so i don't really know haven't
been in
any other states of state areas or
anything like that i've just been
sitting down in the federal area so i
had a chance to experience
was actually like to work and not be
loaded you know yeah i think the drugs
are pretty common
there's a there's a few here and there
that that don't
use but uh a lot of the ones that even
tell you they don't
being honest right but there are some
there's some
sure i'm sure
what's the most important lesson you've
learned of all this especially this year
because you've been through so much
lesson
the big toe get high no matter what
that's the biggest lesson i learned
no matter what because i did and all
these things happened to me
and getting high didn't make it better
i think i was never the answer right i
think i would rather have dealt with
that
stuff sober because maybe i would have a
better outcome
and it wouldn't have gotten as far as it
got where it went
and the rehab you're going to is there
therapy involved in that
um no no no no therapy but you are
allowed to
seek outside therapy i i'm an alumni of
this third
program that i'm going back to and when
i was there i i knew something was
around my middle
so i did it on my own and they allow you
to go and
inquire on your own about your own
mental health but no
it's not it's not dual diagnosis i would
think therapy would be a big part of
recovery
yeah it has to be but they in my
program therapy is called a meeting you
know so you just get in the sponsor
and you just keep you can't hold on to
that
you have anything you'd like to do if
you got clean and got your life together
yeah i'd like to um
make it not amends but i have like a
couple people that hurt out here
you know my best friend so
just like maybe three people that i just
want to say girl i'm not high no more so
let me apologize i see you
well i'm like in the right frame of mind
you know like
i just want to do that kind of situation
not making a man's like the
fellowship says but if i could do this
that helped me feel better and i won't
have built but i won't be holding on to
that
a little bit of that cyber the garbage
that's affected me my life
i you know that's a real important
person the drugs make you do things that
you normally would never
do they're going to make you do things
that you wouldn't never do despicably
the plural horrible they're going to
it's just a matter when
maybe not the beginning but one day
you're going to do some [ __ ]
excuse me some things and you're going
to say damn
i don't believe i just did that that
goes against every
thing i ever taught or believed or
common sense and everything
but that end result
it served his purpose but yeah
definitely gonna do things you just
never thought
that you do i don't care who you are
which tell yourself
even if it's taking 10 cent away from
the your your son that's still something
you thought you would never do as minor
and
slight as it is don't think that that
you never do that to your son
sober right it was only 10 cents
it's something you never thought you
would do you're going to do
all right john i wish you the best of
luck see you soon all right john
thank you thank you yeah i'll be better
when i come back
i'll be better to speak
you